comme prévu le mercredi 31 mai
d'auditionner Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui
dans le cadre
de du dossier qui nous intéresse du
Fonds Marianne
monsieur cifaoui à cette date
n'avait plus se présenter devant nous
pour raison de santé qu'il avait dûment
justifier par un arrêt maladie qui nous
avait été transmis immédiatement
aujourd'hui ce matin très précisément à
8h43 donc il y a un quart d'heure
nous avons reçu
un texte de son avocat que je vais vous
lire de manière très précise je vous
écris à ma qualité d'avocats de Monsieur
Mohamed cifaoui qui aurait dû se
présenter ce jour devant la commission
d'enquête à 9 heures dans le cadre des
auditions relatives à la faire du fond
Marianne il s'avère que depuis six
heures du matin une perquisition est en
cours à son domicile et donc en sa
présence
il n’est en conséquence pas possible
pour celui-ci et pour des raisons vous
en conviendrez totalement indépendante
sa volonté de pouvoir honorer cette
convocation je vous prie de bien vouloir
m'accuser réception du présent mail et
vous prie d'agréer l'expression de ma
parfaite considération voilà le message
que nous avons reçu ce matin
et donc une partie astuce une
perquisition est en cours chez monsieur
cifaoui qui leur retient évidemment
dans son domicile
dès lors cette audition n'aura pas lieu
évidemment avec le rapporteur nous le
regrettons et nous verrons comment nous
pouvons avancer dans ce dossier par la
suite je vous remercie et nous vous
remercions d'être venu ce matin et je
vais vous libérer immédiatement
compte tenu de la situation
[Musique]